joining us now to break down the races
is UNLV assistant professor of political
science Dr Rebecca Gill Dr Gill thanks
for being here just getting word that
Joey Gilbert in the gubernatorial race
is not conceding to sheriff Lombardo and
is actually claiming early on reports
claiming election fraud it leads us into
our first question one side for
Republicans one set for Democrats those
that are all in on the election fraud
issue including you could say Adam
laxalt back with the 2020 election
how will that impact them in your
opinion in the November election
January 6
. Select Committee in Congress is
holding their hearings now and I don't
think we really know exactly how that is
going to land and what taste that's
going to leave in voters and mouths
however you know it does raise the
possibility that being this closely
affiliated with these election fraud
claims could become problematic for
these GOP candidates possibly
problematic for GOP candidates let's go
to the other side of the coin what could
be problematic for Democratic candidates
the inflation issues the gas prices the
food prices with Democratic Leadership
in the presidential Administration right
now and such problems with our economy
how do Democrats overcome that in
November 2020 when the midterms look to
be really in kind of landslide mode if
you will yes and this is typical even
when we don't have these other kinds of
problems I mean the fundamentals show
that the president's party usually
doesn't do that well in the midterms but
I think a lot of this is going to depend
on what happens with the economy with
inflation in the next couple of months
and what is front of mind for voters
that salience issue is going to be very
important in November and if inflation
continues the way it is that's likely to
be the thing that is most Salient to
voters something that's impacting people
on a daily basis appreciate your
perspective on both those sides